in this in the next few videos we're
going to be studying something called
aggregate supply and aggregate demand
and actually we're going to start with
aggregate demand and then start talking
about aggregate supply so we're going to
think about aggregate demand and
aggregate
aggregate i'll rewrite the word
aggregate supply and what i really want
to emphasize in this video is in a lot
of ways it's going to look similar to
traditional supply and demand but i want
to emphasize that there's a very big
difference between aggregate demand and
traditional demand in a macro in a
microeconomic context an aggregate
supply in a macroeconomic context
context and just regular supply in a
microeconomic context and to think about
that let's go to the micro version so
this these are macro economics so we're
looking at an economy as a whole these
are macro
these are macro ideas and to make that
comparison let's revisit the micro the
micro economics ideas of supply and
demand and to do that we can focus on
just a particular market maybe it's the
market for candy bars so this is the
market for candy bars
and we've seen this many many many times
this is most of what we were doing when
we were studying microeconomics on the
vertical axis we would we would plot the
price per unit of the candy bar and in
the horizontal axis you would have the
quantity the quantity bought or sold in
a given amount of time
and we saw that the demand curve tended
to be downward sloping it would look
something like that and then there was
multiple ways to interpret this one way
to interpret this as a at a high price
people would say hey why should i buy
this candy bar i could buy other things
with that money that would make me just
as happy or happier and so they would
purchase a low quantity of it and at a
low price at a low price so this is a
low price right over here people say hey
this is a pretty good deal i can get
candy bars they're so cheap i can buy a
bunch of them instead of buying other
things instead of buying lollipops and
ice cream i'll buy candy bars and then
they'll buy a high quantity of it so
that's one way to interpret it the other
way to interpret it was as essentially
as a marginal benefit curve that very
first few units of candy bars that get
produced there's someone there who just
loves candy bars so much there's a high
willingness to pay for it there's a high
benefit for those first few units but as
you have more and more units the
incremental benefit to the market gets
less and less you could view it as there
are people there who just they still
like candy bars but not as much as the
people who bought those first few units
but that is why you have a downward
sloping curve now when we think about
aggregate demand it's going to look very
similar but the idea is a good bit
different so let's draw i'll do it in a
different color to show that it's
different so now we're in the macro
version and we're talking about
aggregate demand
aggregate demand and so the first thing
to realize is we're talking about
aggregate demand we're thinking about
the economy as a whole we're not just
thinking about the market for just one
good or service and in aggregate demand
what we do is we plot on the horizontal
axis not quantity not just the quantity
bought or sold of one good or service in
amount of time we plot the actual
production of the economy in a given
period of time and we've already studied
that the actual production of the
economy in a given period of time is
real gdp
so we plot on this axis real gdp so it's
really how much are we producing and i
guess there is an analogy to quantity
it's kind of the quantity of
of the productivity of the economy and
in this axis right over here we plot
price level so this is prices but this
isn't price this isn't prices for
one good or service for this isn't just
a price for candy bars this is the
general level of prices in the economy
or maybe you say you know the weighted
average however you want to measure it
some way of measuring the level of
prices and economy and what we will see
is that this is a downward sloping curve
it does look like this
it will look something like this or we
can assume or at least actually
we actually don't know whether it
definitely looks like that but
economists will tell you it looks like
that
based on certain theories and they like
it this way because it starts to explain
based on their models and you can kind
of separate out the emotional aspects of
economics it is one way of potentially
explaining economic cycles although as
you know from the last video i'm
actually a more a stronger believer in
the emotional aspects of it but it will
be downward sloping
it will be
downward sloping like this and once
again this is one product goods or
service right over here this is the
economy as a whole this is just the
general level of prices this is the
actual productivity of the economy so
this is saying and it's a little
unintuitive at first that if prices are
high if prices are high and it's it's
seldom this extreme it's not like the
gdp would go to zero but we'll just
assume it's simplified like this maybe
i'll draw something like this maybe i'll
have it something like
maybe draw something like that so i
don't have to make the extreme statement
that if prices are at some level that
there will be no gdp but it's in general
saying that if prices are high gdp will
contract and if all and remember ceteris
para ceteris paribus all other things
equal if prices are low gdp will expand
and it's happening for completely
different reasons than this downward
sloping this downward sloping was
essentially a substitution effect when
prices are high people said hey i don't
need to buy candy bars i can go buy ice
cream or slurpees or slushies or
something else that makes me happy or
and when prices are low they say hey let
me substitute candy bars for other
things because i'm getting a good deal
on candy bars over here that is not what
is happening what's happening here and
there's a couple of kind of theories why
why economists will justify a downward
sloping aggregate demand curve
so this right here is let me make this
clear this is aggregate demand this is
the demand this is this is this is
essentially saying how much productivity
there will be in the economy as a
function of price levels in the economy
so this is aggregate demand and this is
just demand right over here and there's
three major theories why economists
believe that there is a downward sloping
aggregate demand curve the first is
called the wealth effect
let me write these down the first is
called
the wealth effect
wealth
the first is called
the wealth effect and the wealth effect
is just saying and this is once again
it's a little non-intuitive because when
i you know in my mind when i start
saying hey prices have gone down i start
saying oh well if prices have gone down
wages have gone down and maybe profits
have gone down and then people will get
less optimistic and then the economy
will shrink but that's not what we're
saying in this chart right over here
remember ceteris paribus all other
things equal we're assuming over here
only so if we take this scenario right
over here we're assuming only prices
have gone down everything else in the
economy is equal employment has not
changed profits have not changed
people's people's optimism has not
changed the only thing that changes is
people wake up one day and everything in
the economy is half the price it was
before and people have the same savings
they have the same amount of what money
in their wallet and if that happens all
things equal now they say hey with the
same amount of money that i have in my
wallet i can now buy more i feel
wealthier so that's the wealth effect
they will say i will go and demand more
goods and services because what
with what i have in my pocket i can go
buy more things and likewise if for
whatever reason people woke up the next
morning and remember all other things
equal they said everything the price of
everything were to double they say oh my
god i can't buy anything anymore
everything's too expensive i have to buy
less of it i'm going to demand fewer
goods and services and so the wealth
effect is one theory that would explain
remember all other things equal why you
would have a downward sloping aggregate
aggregate demand curve the other one is
related to interest rates
the other one is related to and i would
call it savings
savings effect savings and interest rate
effect
interest
interest rate
effect
because you can imagine if before if
before this bar represented the total
amount of money someone had in their
pockets and this is how much they needed
to spend on goods and services in order
to have a nice happy productive life and
this is what they were originally going
to save now all of a sudden if things
get a lot cheaper if things get a lot
cheaper they don't have to spend this
much on goods and services they could
spend less on goods and services so
maybe if things got a lot cheaper they
could spend less on goods and services
so now they could spend maybe this
amount on goods and services and they
could save much more so right over here
so if things if everyone remember all
other things equal if everyone woke up
tomorrow and things were just half price
people would be able to spend less on
the things they need and they would be
able to save a lot more money
and we've seen before savings when
people save money it just goes into the
financial system you save it you put it
into the bank and it just gets lent out
to other people and so when you when you
have increase in savings
so remember all other things equal when
prices go down all other things equal
then savings go up which means that the
supply of money the supply of money to
be lent supply of
of lenders or money to be lent
money
lending
goes up and we saw that in a previous
video if you increase the supply of
money that can be lent the price of
borrowing the money will go down or
another way to think about it interest
rates
interest rates will go down and when
interest rates go down it becomes
cheaper you have to spend less interest
to borrow money and make investments you
know borrow money build a house borrow
money build a factory borrow money
do whatever buy inventory and so
interest rates go down that stimulates
that stimulates investment
that stimulates investment which once
again would cause the economy to expand
you would have more goods and services
being produced and likewise if you went
the other way if prices went up so this
is prices this is a situation where
prices went down if prices went up
now all of a sudden people have to spend
more of their money more on the of their
money on what the things that they maybe
think that they need to survive and be
happy and there will be less savings and
if there's less savings then there's
less money to be lent and then there
will be higher interest rates and then
there will be less investment and so the
economy will contract so real gdp
and remember when i say gdp here maybe
i'll call it real gdp
real gdp would go down so this is real
real gdp
would go up and then the third theory of
why or the third i guess justification
because economists like to have this
downward sloping curve so that they can
justify the we'll see how aggregate
supply and demand can cause business
cycles the third effect is essentially
i'll call it a foreign exchange effect
a foreign exchange effect
so foreign
foreign exchange
based on the line of reasoning so let's
say the situation once again where
prices went down based on the line of
reasoning and justification 2 we said if
prices go down then interest rates
interest rates go down because there's
more money to be lent in that economy in
that currency and if interest rates go
down investors might say hey i can get i
only get low interest in my country why
don't i go take why don't i convert my
money into other currencies where i can
get higher interest rates and so if
interest rates go down people convert
out of the currency
convert
out
of
the currency so maybe before if we're
talking about america and where maybe
the interest rates are really low in the
u.s and interest rates are higher in in
the uk maybe because prices didn't go
down there as much people say hey i'm
going to convert my money from dollars
to pound sterling and when they do that
they will they will essentially because
once again if people are converting from
and i've gone in depth on some of the
videos on foreign exchange if people are
converting from dollars to pounds
that means that there's a larger supply
of dollars
and and more demand for pounds so the
price of the dollar relative to the
pound will go down or essentially the
dollar will weaken
the dollar
dollar will weaken relative to other
currencies and if the dollar weakens
relative to other currencies and if this
is a little confusing i go into more
depth into this when i talk about
currency exchange if the dollar weakens
relative to other currencies then
american goods and services are going to
appear to be cheaper to people say in
england for example if i offered to
tutor let's say if i offered to make a
car in america for ten thousand dollars
ten thousand dollars before maybe ten
thousand dollars before this all of this
happened translates into five thousand
pounds but now the dollar has weakened
so now ten thousand dollars is going to
translate into four thousand pounds and
so foreign consumers will say hey wow
american cars just got cheaper when we
viewed in our own currency and so more
and more of them are going to want to
buy american things so america will
export more and once again if there's
more demand for american goods and
services the gdp will expand so this is
related to interest low interest rates
driving people to take currency out or
exchange out of the currency we're
talking about which will make that
currency cheaper which will make its
goods and services cheaper to the rest
of the world
which will essentially once again make
make make net exports increase or you
can really just cut to the chase and say
well look if the price level all of a
sudden in u.s dollars just got cheaper
people say hey there's deals to be had
in the u.s and once again net exports
would increase so once again when you
have low price level you could have lar
you could have gdp expanding and
obviously if the prices were to increase
the the opposite dynamic might occur